so there's been a building sort of
chorus of people both on the trumpian
right and also some on the ante biden
left who have just been insisting that
joe biden
can't possibly hold it together in an
interview
he can't possibly hold it together under
questioning from reporters
and we had finally uh some examples that
we can look at joe biden was interviewed
on abc news over the weekend alongside
his running mate kamala harris this was
the first uh joint interview that they
did i believe
and the interview was remarkable in how
unremarkable
it was from the standpoint of the
hysteria
and the hyperbole and the craziness that
we've become used to under
donald trump it was just like a boring
political interview joe biden
answered questions and he answered
follow-up questions
and he sounded like a politician for
better or worse
and was completely coherent like this
would not normally be news
but it's news when you have people on
both sides
anticipating that joe biden would
devolve
into a stuttering yes he has an actual
stutter
incoherent mess unable to make any point
whatsoever and in fact
i enjoyed the interview not so much
because
i just agree with every policy decision
that is being made by this platform the
biden harris platform
but because it was just normal
and we've been hoping for normal for so
long so let's look at some clips here is
joe biden saying
he would do a national shutdown
or recommend one if public health
officials
said it was the right idea for dealing
with coronavirus remember
it's ultimately up to governors what the
president can do is
recommend and say hey guys let's all do
this
and remember that we still have a raging
pandemic over 180 000
deaths as donald trump continues to
insist we've done and are doing
really well with the virus here is joe
biden sworn in
come january and we have coronavirus and
the flu combining which many scientists
have said is a real possibility
would you be prepared to shut this
country down again
i would be prepared to do whatever it
takes to save lives because we cannot
get the country moving
until we control the virus that is the
fundamental flaw of this
administration's thinking to begin with
in order to keep the country running and
moving and the economy growing
and people employed you have to fix the
virus you have to deal with the virus
so if the scientists say shut it down i
would shut it down
i would listen to the scientist now
immediately you had people come out and
say oh my god
what a socialist authoritarian he wants
no country
he wants no economy he wants no
businesses
come on guys come on haven't we learned
enough at this point haven't we seen
what happened in other countries
versus in the united states when people
wore masks and they took social
distancing seriously
and when you have to shut down sectors
of the economy temporarily you do it but
then you're able to reopen
biden is not saying any if you're
shocked at what biden's saying
then then essentially you're saying the
whole world handled it incorrectly we
we handled it correctly and we have one
of the highest per capita death rates
in the world biden is just being
sensible
this is a medical situation just a
candidate recognizing that
distinguishes them from donald trump we
have to defer to public health and
medical officials that's it
that's what we need in this country and
people are going crazy about
authoritarian joe biden now on top of
that
had we done a two-month coordinated
shutdown meaning
essential businesses only everybody
wears masks
no school back in april or may
we never would have gotten to where we
are today which is in an emergency
situation
with one of the worst coronavirus
responses
in the world people are reacting to
biden
like he's the outlier biden is just
saying let's do what the rest of the
world figured out months ago
no more no less then joe biden is asked
because again trump has been criticizing
biden for being in his basement
joe biden was asked can you win a
presidential election from your house
take a look
i understand the restrictions of covid
and campaigning in this time but can you
win a presidential election
from home we will we're going to follow
the science
what the scientists tell us we've been
able to travel places when we've been
able to do it in a way that we don't
cause the congregation of large numbers
of people
look what happens what's happened with
his his
events people die people get together
they don't wear masks they end up
getting covered they end up dying
so when you hear the president say this
guy's afraid to leave his basement
guess what i have left my basement
and but here in the meantime 500 million
people have watched what i've done out
of my basement
and guess what people are listening
people are listening
it's about being responsible i really
think that this is creating controversy
where there is no controversy here and
what's going to be really interesting is
for three and a half years we've had
this narrative from trump
that the fake news media is all against
them all the media's against them except
fox news
and even fox news sometimes is against
them so you've got to go to oan
to find fair media what a lot of people
have forgotten
i have not forgotten it is that the myth
of the liberal media is a myth
this is a corporatist media with a
penchant
for salaciousness and controversy and
right away
they are taking hook line and sinker
every narrative set by
trump here they're asking about biden in
his basement guys there's a pandemic
biden's being responsible that's it
okay and then they continue to take
debate the bait corporate media does
by asking biden about the attacks donald
trump has been making against biden on
his cognitive fitness now
i happen to think it's fair when you
have candidates
that are in their 70s trump
now mid 70s biden closer to 80.
it's totally reasonable to ask about
cognitive fitness
but what's fascinating here is that
corporate supposedly fake news
left-leaning corporate media
they're taking trump's bait on every one
of these issues biden in the basement
and now biden's cognitive fitness
i want to turn to the blistering attacks
we've seen from president trump just
this week alone
on your mental fitness whether you're up
for the job
his campaign has called you diminished
and i'm curious
how you'd respond to that watch me mr
president
watch me look at us both what we say
what we do
what we control what we know what kind
of shape we're in
come on look i think it's a legitimate
question to ask anybody
over 70 years old whether or not they're
fit and whether they're ready
but uh i just the only thing i can say
the american people
it's a legitimate question to ask
anybody watch me
let's put the attacks aside then the
american people remember ronald reagan
was 77
when he left office you would be 78
entering office and
you have said yourself that you are a
transition candidate
does that mean a one-term president what
is that no it doesn't mean so you're
leaving
open the possibility you'll serve eight
years
okay so joe biden handling it perfectly
perfectly well and
i do think much like before the bernie
biden debate you had all these people
expecting oh my god
if biden's up against bernie one on one
biden's gonna collapse
and of course he didn't and he went on
to win the primary they were
disappointed
and i think they're going to be
disappointed again in debates against
trump
if they happen i don't expect any kind
of collapse
from joe biden biden also was
interviewed by abc's robin roberts asked
about choosing kamala harris and again
this is not a particularly newsworthy
clip it's just notable that joe biden
is normal he's able to articulate why he
selected kamala harris
uh he's able to speak in complete
compound sentences
we've just become unaccustomed to it
take a look there's a connection there
that i'm going to talk more about where
it comes to bow and
and other aspects of family you eluded
mr vice president about the fact that
you made it clear early on
that you were going to select a woman to
be your running mate you select
a woman of color did you do that to
rally
your base did you feel pressure to
select a black woman
no i didn't feel pressure to select a
black woman but i what i do think and
i've said it before and you've heard me
say it i probably
said it on your show with you is that
the government should look like the
people
look like the country 51 percent of the
people in this country are women
that that old expression goes women hold
up half the sky
and in order to be able to succeed
you've got to be
dealt in across the board and no matter
what you say
you cannot i cannot understand and
fully appreciate what it means to walk
in her shoes to be
an african-american woman with an
indian-american background
a child of immigrants she can't assume
exactly what it's like to walk in my
shoes
what we do know is we have the same
value set and uh
and i really mean that and so it was uh
it was easy for me
it was an easy decision to make although
there are enormous number of
really qualified women i spoke to every
single woman
that was on the list before and
as i the day i made the choice before
anything was announced i called every
single one of them
so what was the tipping point the
tipping point was i was
it was there were several things but it
just seemed to fit
the closest and the best i thought i
understood
and i think i understand her where she
comes from
what her instincts are her her character
i watched her take on the big banks i
watched her take on the gun lobby i
watched her
the way she was a prosecutor i watched
her as a united states senator
isn't this so weird that joe biden just
answers questions
and stays on topic and doesn't ramble
and again uses compound sentences
now then asked whether she
still agrees with her prior call for
more police officers on the streets
which has been
really the big liability for kamala
harris
she doesn't directly answer as
politicians
often avoid doing instead she praises
black lives matter
as important also been a national
conversation about
policing and you know the name that you
have kamala top cop
and the book that you wrote 10 years ago
smart on crime
where you concluded by saying that you
wanted to see more police
on the street do you still feel that way
listen i think that there is no question
first of all when i
wrote that book um
we black lives matter did not exist
and i give full credit to the brilliance
of that movement in terms of what it has
done to advance
a conversation that needed to happen a
long time ago
what black lives matter has done as a
movement
has been to be a counter force against
a very entrenched status quo around the
criminal justice system in america
and that's why i'm so excited about what
we can do
in terms of a new administration in the
white house
okay so kamala harris is sort of
equivocating she's saying black lives
matter is good
she's saying well what i did before was
a while ago
you can't really explain it any
differently other than to say
i was attorney general at the time and i
was doing my job
this is this is standard politics and we
don't have to like it but again
it's not about whether you accept
kamala's answer
it's about the reality that these are
just normal people
who relate to the media normally who
relate to their families normally
who can complete a thought and that has
been
so missing for years in this country
meanwhile donald trump did not have a
very good weekend let's talk about that
next
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the
important core ideas and information
from that book
it's perfect if you don't have enough
time to do all the reading you want to
do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video